[Musique]
notre univers d'une merveilleusement
mystérieux il arrive si souvent qui
piège et tromper nos yeux
des siècles de génie ont voulu - se
tromper ils ont développé des outils
pour mieux penser
en 741 un doute méthodique fut entrepris
par le grand philosophe descartes dans
son oeuvre les méditations métaphysiques
l'existence d'un malin génie pointe y
lit car ce tte monde des cartes est un
être tout puissant capable de falsifier
nos données sensorielles mais aussi nos
facultés intellectuelles lui présent
rien ne peut être exclu
entièrement
[Musique]
en 1814 dans un essai splendide la place
la place inventa une intelligence qui de
tout notre univers où réconnaissance
pour elle passé présent futur serait
limpide ce démon de la place serait donc
en mission
il lui suffirait de connaître l'état
présent car les lois de newton en
imposerait l'avenir il serait donc tout
ce que vous allez choisir
puis en 1867 james clerk maxwell résolu
le problème du mouvement perpétuel en
invoquant un démon capable de trier et
ce faisant notre hobby pouvait diminuer
ce démon de max ul traiter l'information
et fournissait du travail et de
l'énergie
il semblait défier le temps et sa
direction
initiant la la physique de l'algorithme
l'information ne serait ainsi pas
gratuite elle semble même correspondent
à une grandeur physique l'univers
imposerait aux calculs des limites
c'est la thèse de church turing en
version quantique
voilà qui en mettra beaucoup solomonoff
son induction nécessitaient de gros
calculs des calculs d'une monstruosité
ridicule les limites physiques semblait
être une catastrophe
selon mme nov prouva même que son
induction est du domaine de l'ain
calculabilité aucun engin ne peut faire
ses opérations
les calculs risque de tourner sans
s'arrêter
l'induction de solomonoff et inhumaine
elle est également hors de portée des
machines tout bayésienne n'est donc ni
homme ni machine un démon télé ce qu'est
cette pure bayésienne en l'honneur du
grand génie qui la définit je vais
l'appeler le démon de solomonoff équipé
d'une infinité de théorie il respecte
les instructions de solomonoff en digne
successeur d'une descendance de démon
lui aussi défie les lois de
l'information pour toucher de plus près
l'étendue du savoir en transcendant les
limites du calculatoire
[Musique]
le démon de solomonoff hors de portée ne
serait-il pas possible d'au moins
l'approcher certes ces théories sont
bien en nombre infini mais tous ne sont
pas crédibles
a priori en fait si on dispose de
milliards de données les théories
décrite en trilliards de symboles auront
un poids qu'on peut largement négligé ne
pas les considérer semble une bonne
bricole en fait ce n'est pas là qu'est
la difficulté
le problème est de certifier car code
donné décrit justement une loi de
probabilité et en particulier il faut
bien vérifier que pour tout donner entre
et il va terminer
voilà qui défie la calculabilité
[Musique]
en fait et solomon of a même démontré
que la complétude guerlain calculabilité
[Musique]
il s'agit du théorème dit d'incomplétude
dont la conclusion est incroyablement
rude il dit quel que soit votre
algorithmes d'induction il existera
nécessairement des univers où à tout
instant chacune de vos prédictions sera
13 et rhône et tout ira de travers
[Musique]
on a vu les ingrédients de tel univers
dans l'épisode du paradoxe de chief
audel ces univers font vos calculs et
font l'envers il n'y a rien à faire
l'incomplétude et cruel
en fait la situation est même pire
encore solomonov a prouvé que son
induction ne possédait aucune forme
d'approximations
qu'ils soient à la fois calculable et
uniforme dix autres ont pour tout
algorithmes d'induction il existe un
passé tels que ces prédictions divergent
solomonoff et de ses calculs cet
algorithme est alors infiniment nul
le baiia nisme décrit par solomonoff se
trouve donc être extrêmement
incalculables en un sens il est même
très in approximative et ça il faut bien
le dire c'est une catastrophe
mais à y réfléchir il s'agit en fait là
d'un défaut d'une version de modèles
bayésiens
on peut en effet avoir d'autres
résultats avec par exemple des a priori
distincts après tout d'autres univers
semble lui-même contraint pour calculer
la prochaine données collectées il
semble mettre un temps fixe et
prédéterminés il n'a qu'un jour pour
calculer le lendemain il semble alors
juste de seulement considérer des
théories avec tant de calcul fixé comme
typiquement les automates cellulaires
ceci semble plus adapté à notre univers
avec ses théories
le truc super chouette c'est que
l'induction bayésienne est calculable
car ces théories sont constructivement
dénombrable l'induction est alors
calculable et complète
si l'univers est un automate cellulaire
l'induction benziane calculera ses états
et fournira les meilleures possibles
résultats sans violer la calculabilité
de l'univers
alors il reste quand même un gros bémol
ma foi
mais ce bémol non parlera une prochaine
fois
alors l'induction de ce logo 9
incalculable méritait-elle l'apologie
que j'en ai fait
elle a beau être une jolie induction
complète
en pratique elle est ultra ina proxima
bhl en fait il semble utile d'y voir un
idéal certes inatteignable mais d'une
pureté sans égal elle est une sorte de
prédiction vers laquelle tendre une
inspiration pour mieux apprendre et
comprendre
l'induction de solomonoff elle kaparfait
l'approché est un vaste et formidable
projet
un projet d'une difficulté très
redoutable un projet surtout fascinant
est formidable